What advice would you give to someone looking to quit porn?
Well,
I gave some advice a little earlier about quitting alcohol.
You know,
and I would say it isn't that you're turning to quit porn.
It's not the right way to think about it.
The right way to think about it is that you're trying to figure out how to have
a better life.
And so you have to figure out,
well I would say do the future authoring program and keep your porn addiction in
mind and think so in the first part of the future authoring program,
it asks you a bunch of questions about what your life could be like in three to
five years if you took care of yourself like you were someone that you cared
for.
Um,
and then it asks you questions about your friends and your family and your
career and your time outside of work and your health and you know,
the important dimensions of life.
And it,
it asks you to spend
20 minutes writing about how good your life could be in three to five years if
you got your act together and did what was good for you.
And then it asked you to write about the hell you could be in if you didn't.
And so I would say you really need to do that because porn isn't the issue.
The issue is that you're not living your life the way you want to.
And so you need a vision of life that's more compelling than the porn.
And you need a counter vision to that frightens you.
You know,
because otherwise porn is obviously extraordinarily gratifying in the short
term,
but,
but you seem to be suffering from the medium to longterm consequences of its
use.
And so you need a story that you can tell yourself that's really deeply thought
through about why this is not appropriate for you.
What's what,
it's how it's hurting you and how it's minimizing you and perhaps making you
embarrassed and ashamed and more socially isolated and all of that.
So I would say think about it as cleaning up your psyche and your behavior
rather than merely start stopping,
stopping poor.
And you also might want to write down,
and you could do this in a negative vision,
part of the future authoring program.
You got to write down everything bad that you think porn is doing to you,
because obviously you have some suspicions that this is not good for you,
right?
That it's,
that it's actually harming you in some important way.
And so you need to be fully cognizant of what those ways are and then take them
seriously and decide if that's the pathway through life on which you wish to
travel and so on.
Then I would also say good luck to you.
You know,
it's,
it's a very good idea to identify one of your weaknesses and work on it on you
can,
you can strengthen yourself substantially by,
dude.